how hard is it to get the humanoid robot
Atlas
to do some of the things it's recently
been doing let's forget the flips and
all of that let's just look at the
running
maybe you can correct me but there's
something about running I mean that's
not careful at all that's your falling
forward
you're jumping forward and you're
falling so how hard is it to get that
right our first humanoid
we needed to deliver natural looking
walking you know we took a contract from
the army they wanted a robot that could
walk naturally they wanted to put a suit
on the robot and be able to test it in a
gas environment and so they wanted that
the motion to be natural
and so our goal was a natural looking
gate it was real it was surprisingly
hard to get that to work and we but we
did build an early machine
we called it Petman prototype it was the
Prototype before the Pac-Man robot
and it had a really nice looking
gate where you know it would stick the
leg out it would do heel strike first
before it rolled onto the toe so you
didn't land with a flat foot you
extended your leg a little bit
um but even then it was hard to get the
robot to walk where when you're walking
that I fully extended its leg and
essentially landed on an extended leg
and if you watch closely how you walk
you probably land on an extended leg but
then you immediately flex your knee as
you start to make that contact
and getting that all to work well
took such a long time in fact I I
probably didn't really see the nice
natural walking that I expected out of
our humanoids until maybe last year
and the team was developing on our newer
generation of Atlas you know some new
techniques
for developing a walking control
algorithm and they got that natural
looking motion as sort of a byproduct of
a of a just a different process they
were applying to developing the control
so that probably took 15 years 10 to 15
years to sort of get that from from you
know the Petman prototype was probably
in 2008 and what was a 2022 last year
that I think I saw a good walking on
Atlas if you could just like link on it
what are some challenges of getting good
walking so is it uh
is this is this partially like a
hardware like actuator problem is it the
control is it the artistic element of
just observing the whole system
operating in different conditions
together I mean is there some kind of
interesting
quirks or challenges you can speak to
like the heel strike yeah so one of the
things that makes the like this straight
leg uh a challenge is you're sort of up
against a singularity a mathematical
single Singularity where you know when
your leg is fully extended it can't go
further the other direction right
there's only you can only move in One
Direction and that makes all of the
calculations around how to produce
twerks at that joint or positions makes
it more complicated and so having all
the mathematics so it can deal with
these singular configurations is one of
many challenges uh that we face and I'd
say in in the
you know in those earlier days again we
were working with these really
simplified models so we're trying to
boil all the physics of the complex
human body into a simpler subsystem that
we can more easily describe in
mathematics and sometimes those simpler
subsystems don't have all of that
complexity of the straight leg built
into them and so what's happened more
recently is we're able to apply
techniques that let us take the full
physics of the robot into account and
and deal with some of those strange
situations like this like the straight
leg so is there a fundamental challenge
here that it's uh maybe you can correct
me but is it under actuated are you
falling under actuated is the right word
right you can't you can't uh push the
robot in any direction you want to right
and so that that is one of the hard
problems of of uh like a Locomotion and
you have to do that for natural movement
it's not necessarily required for
natural movement it's just required
you know we we don't have you know a
gravity force that you can hook yourself
onto to apply uh an external force in
the direction you want at all times
right the only the only external forces
are being mediated through your feet and
how they get mediated depending on how
you place your feet and uh you know you
can't just uh you know God's hand can't
reach down and give and push in any
direction you want you know so is there
uh is there some extra challenge to the
fact that Alice is such a big robot
there is the humanoid form is um
attractive in many ways but it's also a
challenge in many ways
um
you have this big upper body that has a
lot of mass and inertia
um and throwing that inertia around
increases the complexity of maintaining
balance and as soon as you pick up
something heavy in your arms you've made
that problem even harder
and so uh in the early work in the leg
lab and in the early days at the company
and we were pursuing these quadruped
robots which had a
a kind of built-in simplification you
have this big rigid body and then really
light legs so when you swing the legs
the leg motion didn't impact the body
motion very much all the mass and
inertia was in the body but when you
have the humanoid that doesn't work you
have big heavy legs you swing the legs
it affects everything else
and so
dealing with all of that interaction
does make the humanoid a much more
complicated platform